Welcome back. We now launch into the study of distributed systems. This is an
exciting field. On a personal note, I
started my academic career as a researcher of
distributed systems in the mid 80s. Part of the fun, but there's a lot
of parallels between distributed systems and parallel
systems. What fundamentally distinguishes a distributed system from
a parallel system is the individual autonomy for
the nodes of a distributed system as compared to
a parallel system, and the fact that the interconnection
network that connects all the nodes in a distributed
system is wide open to the world, as
opposed to being confined within Iraq. Or a room
or a box. However, as the feature size of
transistors in silicon continues to shrink due to advances
in process technology and break throughs in
VLSI technology, many of the issues that are
considered to be in the domain of distributed
systems and are surfacing even within a single
chip. But I digress. In this lesson
we are going to learn the fundamental communication
mechanisms in distributed systems and what an operating
system has to do to make communication efficient.
As in the previous lessons, you will
see the symbiotic relationship. Between hardware in the
form of networking gear and the operating system
software stack, particularly the protocol stack, to make
the communication efficient. We'll start this lesson
module with a definition and a shared understanding
of what we mean by a distributed system. But first, a quiz to get you started.